[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
wednesday july 13th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
for the last couple of years spacex has
been launching satellites into orbit to
form starlink an internet providing web
that as of june was serving 400 000
customers globally
but spacex says its signals could be
hampered if the federal communications
commission approves new rules to expand
the spectrum for 5g wireless service
it's facing opposition though
tv operator dish
wants those frequencies added to support
its future business plans
so how is the battle shaking out and
what will it mean for internet customers
joining us to discuss this is wsj
telecoms reporter drew fitzgerald
hey drew thanks for coming on the show
sure thanks for having me
let's just start with some basics what
exactly is the fcc doing and what would
it mean in terms of you know how we use
the internet and get access to it what
the fcc is reviewing is whether it can
change its rules for wireless spectrum
and these are the radio waves over the
air that cell phones satellite tvs
satellite internet services airplanes
that are connected to wi-fi it's what
they all use to communicate with the
wider world a particular frequency band
that is mostly used for satellite
service right now
that's what this is all about some
companies want the rules rewritten to
make room for 5g service from cell phone
towers
while others want to keep it restricted
to satellite use as it is today so the
debate is really all about internet
service and specifically the best way to
provide that service over the year
so dish network is one of the companies
that's in favor of this change how would
it benefit them why would they support
it well dish is actually a tv company
that's been slammed by cord cutting like
everybody else so it's chairman has made
a big bet on 5g networks that are built
on the ground
and dish has another big supporter in a
company owned by michael dell another
billionaire who's invested in telecom
and a lot of technology obviously before
okay but you know companies like spacex
they don't want regulators to do this
what's their argument
well spacex's internet business which is
called starlink has been putting
thousands of satellites into orbit over
the past few years and those satellites
use some of these frequencies today to
communicate with their customers
spacex's main argument against the rule
changes is that 5g service in this
particular band of frequencies it's
saying that that's going to interfere or
drown out the signal from its existing
satellites
so pretty much spacex is arguing if you
change the rules that its internet isn't
going to be as robust as it is at the
moment
exactly it's arguing that if the rules
change in the way that some are
proposing
that
its service will be degraded and
the internet speeds and the reliability
that they have achieved so far from
satellites in the sky
will be lessened and that a lot of their
customers won't have internet service
that's as good as it is today
and a lot of starlink's customers are in
remote areas where there's not cable
internet or any other kind of high-speed
internet service available so that
leaves their customers with few choices
if in fact their service is going to be
affected
so dish and its supporters are in favor
of these changes spacex and other
companies like it don't want the changes
to come through
how are these companies stepping up
their efforts to convince regulators to
take their side
well they're stepping up their lobbying
game both sides they've been going to
the federal communications commission
many times over the past few months
making their case in meetings and
in filings
arguing that the science is basically on
their side
ultimately what this is is an
engineering decision and it's up to the
fcc
to decide not what the new rules should
be but basically whether the rules
should be examined whether they should
be changed at all and whether it's
possible for these two types of internet
services these two types of technologies
to co-exist in the same airwaves in the
same airspace
so that's what's before the fcc i should
also add that both companies have spent
a decent amount of time through their
lobbyists on capitol hill
and there have been hearings held on
this and
also a lot of activity on capitol hill
from both sides trying to marshal
senators and members of congress to make
the case for them in washington i mean
this seems like a really technical
argument from both sides but it is
essentially about internet use so should
regular internet customers be concerned
about how this debate shakes out
well starlink argues that they should
and that's another development that's
happened over the past few weeks
from spacex the company sent emails to a
lot of its customers essentially urging
them to write their congress person and
to write the fcc
urging these officials to not change the
status quo and to protect their internet
service and that's something that a lot
of companies will commonly do they'll
marshal a lot of their customers to make
their case in washington
we'll see how much of an effect that has
like many of elon musk's companies the
starlink customer base is a very
passionate customer base and after just
a few weeks there have been more than 95
000 comments filed in the system
on this particular issue but at the end
of the day it's not the politicians but
it's civil servants career
engineering types that are looking at
this record and deciding what to do next
do we have any timeline on when we
should expect a decision from them
it's really up to the fcc there's no
stop clock on this and
it could go on for weeks it could go on
for years
all right we'll just have to keep an eye
on it and see how things shake out
that's our reporter drew fitzgerald
thanks for joining us drew thanks for
having me
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
you